[موسيقى]
يا ريت الواقع سهل مثل الحكي
بيكبر بضله محافظ على هالبراءه هاي هي
الفطره اللي الله خلقنا عليها
حلم محمود هو انه يصير بيانيس
هل الكلام هو الوسيله الوحيده للتعبير عن
الافكار والمشاعر قالها ابو الفلسفه
الحديثه ديكارت انا افكر اذا انا موجود لم
يقل انا اتكلم اذا انا موجود كم وسيله
للتواصل نجد حولنا الرسم لغه والموسيقى
لغه والغناء والكتابه والرياضه لغه وحتى
للعيون لغه كل منا مختلف نتقاسم الكثير
ونختلف في الكثير ايضا كذلك اصحاب التوحد
متشابهون ومختلفون فالاختلاف هو التنوع
والتنوع هو الحياه
منذ ان اكتشف الطب التوحد قبل ثمانيه عقود
ما زال نصفه من حولنا يره لغزا ونصف ذلك
النصف لا يحاول ان يعرف اي شيء عن التوحد
حتى العلم اختلف بشانه البعض يراه اضطرابا
نفسيا او عصبيا والبعض الاخر يراه اشكالا
جنيا بيولوجيا لماذا لا نعرف الكثير عن
التوحد
اليوم نحاول الوصول اليهم لن نبحث عن سبب
ولا عن طبيب ولا عن علاج انها مهمه خاصه
نذهب فيها اليهم لنعرف بماذا يفكرون وماذا
يشعرون هل يعيشون اللحظه فقط ام لديهم
احلام وامنيات هل يعرفون المراهقه ما هو
الكذب او المجامله بالنسبه اليهم هل
يعرفون انهم مختلفون
كنا لنكتفي لو عرفنا الاجابه ولو على بعض
هذه الاسئله استحاله الوصول الى الكل
اوصلتنا الى القليل منهم الى حيث محمود
شاب يعيش ربيع العشرين وفي قصته رساله لكل
انسان
[موسيقى]
مرات بمراحل الخمسه عيد قبل الرس مثل ما
هي ما تركت مرحله ما مرقت فيها
واتمنى النكران
من مرحله نكران انه انا لا لا ابني ما ما
معه توحد لابني ما معه شي هيدي مرحله
وبتمرق بتعرفي كيف الام بصير بتضحك على
حالها يعني وبتتخبى وراء اصبعها بعدين
مرحله الغضب بعد مرحله الغضب انه ليش هو
عم بيتفاعل معي ليش محمود هو معه توحد
مع العلم انه ولا مره سالت حالي او سالت
رب العالمين انه ليش انا
كنت انا صغير
كان بابا يغني لي بالفورد شو بحبك لما
بتحكي شو بحبك لما بتحكي ترسم عشفافك ضحكي
شو بحبك لما بتبكي بتشكي وعم بتغلغل فيه
حبيبي انت الاحلى عمري
وفي بعض الاحيان فكرت بالانتحار
بعض الاحيان كنت اتمنى الموت انا وابني
لانه انا موتي انا ما رح يجيب نتيجه
بالنهايه ابن حايضل لحاله وهيدا مش الشي
اللي انا بدي اياه
فانا لما حسيت اني انا خلاص ذوقت وذرعا
بقولوا خلاص ما عاد بقى قادره اتحمل هذه
الفاتن النكديه والاكتئاب والحزن
بلشت بقى
ابحث عن حلول نفسيه فرحت درست سايكو
دراماثيرابيست
لانه انا كنت مقتنعه انه انا مش رح يمشي
حالي بجلسه وجلستين ولا سنه وسنتين انا
مقتنعه انه انا بحاجه اني انا اعرف كيف
اتعامل مع مشاعري وافهم نفسيتي
لكل العمر لانه انا عارفه الوضع اللي انا
فيه حيرافقني كل العمر
شو حلو حبيبي شو حلو
هالقمر شوفوا ما اجمله بس انا عبالي دلل
وحياتي ما حدا بقى يزعلوه
انا ما بحب زعل حدا ابدا
اوقات الدنيا بتوجعني
بتعاند وياي
لا بخاف وحاخاف ازاي يعني
دايما مطمن طول ما انت معايا
طبيبه نفسيه تاثرت خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بقوه التعاطف والمرونه للروح
الانسانيه وفي عام
1969 عرضت نموذجا معروفا باسمها عن مراحل
الحزن الخمس من خلال هذا النموذج ارادتروس
التحدث بصوت عال عن مشاعر يمر بها الانسان
امام صدمه تهز سلامه النفسي
المراحل الانتقاليه في منحنى التغيير لقبل
الروس تبدا بصدمه تؤدي الى الانكار بعد
ذلك يتملكون الغضب ثم يبدا التفاوض مع
الذات في حوار من طرف واحد نريد الخروج من
الازمه ولكن بلا اي مجهود ثم نقع في
الاكتئاب ويبدا الحزن والياس وكل الافكار
السلبيه بالهجوم مره واحده ولكن التقبل هو
بدايه الحل مرحله الغضب
هي مرحله تغضب فيها الام من نفسها
ومن حب لابنه تشعر في الكره يعني هي نحن
ترتقي الام انه هي بتكره ابنها ولكن في
الحقيقه في علم النفس هي مرحله الغضب في
قبل الراس الغضب من نفسها لانه هي عم تشعر
بهذا المشاعر واللي هي للاسف طبيعيه لو
عنا نحن الوعي النفسي والثقافه النفسيه ما
كانت حتجلط حاله
[موسيقى]
انا مجرد ما وصلت للتقبل لا وضع ابني بلش
يعطيني نتائج
اذا بدك انا ناطرتها من سنين تعب سنين
عليه بلش يعطيني اياه لما وصلت لحالي من
التقبل انه خلص انا متقبلته كيف ما كان
وشو ما كان تقدم ما تقدم خلاص هيدا هو
ابني وبدي حبه متل ما هو وهيدا هو المفتاح
الذهبي قبلت بمحمود كما هو كاي ام ارادته
ان يرقد اليها لكن ما حدث كان العكس لم
تحقق فاتن احلامها بتخرج محمود من الجامعه
وبشهاده دراسات عليا محمود فتح لها بابا
الى عالمه فادهشها وانساها الحياه النمطيه
والصراع والتنافس ومسابقه الزمن في كل شيء
يعني انا كنت خاف انه انا يصير لي شي
ومحمود كيف بده ياكل ما هو ما بيعرف يقول
ياكل انا انا بدي اكل ما بقول انا عطشان
انا بروح بشربه بس انا الشيء اللي بقلقني
واللي عطلت همه محمود طلع منه الحمد لله
تعتبري انه محمود هو اللي قام بالانجاز
الكبير ام فاتن
اكيد محمود
شفنا نحن بمجتمعنا اوكي
منكرم الام وبنشوف التعب بس للاسف
ما بنعرف قيمه التعب اللي هن بيتعبوا متل
ما نحنا منتعب هن بيتعبوا على حالهم يعني
منو شي سهل عليهم منه شي سهل عليهم لانه
هن
نحنا عم نكسر لهم طبيعتهم
لحتى اذا بدك انا بقول لك اكثر نحن عم
نشوههم عم نشوه لهم فطرتهم ليصيروا
يشبهونا
[موسيقى]
لان القصص تتشابه ذهبنا الى نيراج الصبي
الموهوب في الرسم والالعاب الالكترونيه
صبي لا يتجاوز اثني عشر عاما يتحدث ويقرا
ويكتب وله بيت صغير فيه عائله ومدرسه
واصدقاء
[موسيقى]
عدست
عامتيزن في ذلك الوقت لم اكن اعرف شيئا عن
التوحد وكنت اتساءل لماذا لا يتكلم فانه
ياكل وينام جيدا وسلوكه عادي ولكن عندما
اناديه لا ياتي ولا ينظر الي حتى عندما
اصبح عمره ثلاث سنوات لم يكن يتكلم وكان
يصدر اصواتا فقط في ذلك الوقت كنت اعرف
فقط بعض الاطفال مما لديهم مشكلات في
النمو ولم اكن اعرف شيئا عن التوحد عندما
عدت الى البيت بحثت في الانترنت فوجدت
اشياء اخافتني يا ليتني لم الجا الى
الانترنت كان كل شيء سلبيا عن التوحد
لكنني مع ذلك رايت نفس الاعراض التي اراها
في ابني
[موسيقى]
هل تهربت من حالتي نراجع
يمكنني ان اقول ذلك لانني كنت في حاله عدم
التقبل لابني وهذا يعد هروبا من الواقع
ولو بطريقه غير مباشره ربما حاله النكران
في اللاوعي هي نتيجه رفض التقبل والتاقلم
لانك لا تعرف كيف تتصرف وتصاب بحاله ظهر
طبعا ارتيميا ساعدتني للخروج من هذه
الحاله واعادتني الى الواقع قالت لي ان
حاله ابننا لن تختفي فجاه ولن يشفى بحبه
دواء وينتهي الامر بعدما رايت ما تفعله هي
الهمتني لاكون جزءا من هذه المهمه مع
نيراج وبدات اساعد حينما اكون قادرا على
ذلك فبدء التحول من عدم القيام باي شيء
الى محاوله المساعده
[موسيقى]
ارى انني ابو لطفل لا يعاني من التوحد
وهذا ما يشعرني براحه نفسيه عارمه وانما
اقدمه لنيراج ليس لانه طفل توحد وانما
لانه طفل عادي هذا حقه ولذلك توقفت عن جلد
الذات لانه طفل توحد وهذه شهاده للتطور
الذي احرزه نيران
[موسيقى]
وانهي 5
عندما اصبح عمره خمس سنوات قمنا بزياره
طبيبه نفسيه قالت لي ان ابننا لن يكون
قادرا على الكلام ولن يصبح طفلا عاديا
تخيلي هذا ما قالته لي عن ابني ولكن ابني
يتحدث الان لا يمكن لطبيبه ان تقول ذلك
لاي ام لانها ستسرق منها الامل
[موسيقى]
يونيتها يجب ان تعطى الامهات بعض الامل
كان يجب عليها كطبيبه ان تنصحني بقراءه
كتاب او فعل هذا الامر او ذاك كان يجب
عليها ان تكون ايجابيه
نعم
لم اقم بتربيه الحيوانات في البيت يوما
ولكن عندما علمت ان اطفال التوحد يتفاعلون
مع الكلاب دفعته الى اللعب معها في
الحديقه العامه واحب ذلك فعلا واليوم اصبح
لدينا قطط في البيت ويحب اللعب معها كما
يشاء حاولت ان العب كره القدم معها لكنه
رفض فركزت على الاشياء التي يهتم بها هو
الان هذا ما يضيف الى تفاعله كاي شخص اخر
حاول الطبيبه ان تسرق منها الامل لكنها
فشلت مرتين كطبيبه وكانسانه هذا ما حدث مع
ارتيميا التي نسيت حياتها تماما لتغرق في
البحث عن مصادر وكتب موثوقه تدلها الى
الطريق الى الوصول الى ابنها لم تكن
مهمتها سهله بسبب ندره الكتب التعليميه
واللافت هنا ان من كتب غالبيه الكتب عن
التوحد هم اصحاب توحد
احد المعالجين قال لي انه يجب ان اقوم
ببعض التمارين معه وهو تمرين تذوق الماء
المالح والحلم والمر والحامض لتحفيز
الاحساس لديه
[موسيقى]
اين صوره الهاتف
جيد جدا
اين صوره الطبخ جيد جدا ميراج اخرجت الامل
من الالم لتوصل ابنها الى القراءه
والكتابه والرسم والتعبير عن نفسه وحتى
المشاركه في مسابقات ومنافسات مع اخرين هم
ليسوا في عالم خاص بهم هم في عالمنا
[موسيقى]
كان الامر صعب في البدايه وسبب ضغطا نفسيا
والان ارى ابني يمكنه الكلام وقادر على ان
يطلب ما يشاء ولديه سلوك جيد في المجتمع
وكل يوم يتعلم اشياء كثيره انا ارى ابني
طفلا عاديا لا اريد طفلا اخر بديلا عن
هم لا يعرفون انهم مختلفون نحن من نخلق
الاختلاف ونشعرهم به كسر ادركوا هذه
الحقيقه ومنهم ناهد الام التي تريد الذهاب
بهم الى اقصى ما لديهم ان تكتشف مهاراتهم
في فضاء يجمعهم حيث لا اختلاف ولا تنمر
اتت فكره ماي ماكس من احمد ولله الحمد انا
ناهده الام قبل اي شيء بنات كل هذا المكان
وانا بحلم في مكان لاحمد اشوف احمد فيهم
اشوف احمد عنده حياه وكانت احلامي كاي ام
كبيره جدا للاسف بعد ما بنيت المكان هذا
احمد احتياجاته مختلفه واصبح احمد اليوم
ما موجود في هذا المكان لكن اصبح المكان
لكل الاحمدات الموجودين في هذه الحياه
اصبح عندي اكثر من احمد اصبح عندي علي
اصبح عندي خالد بنادوني يا امي وابني انا
ما بتكلم بعد رحلتي مع احمد الطويله احمد
هو احمد قال تغيرت انا
احمد فحبيت انا انه اغير احمد احمد ما
بتغير
[موسيقى]
احمد الداني قوه مضاعفه فان اكون انا
الشخص الان اللي يقدر يساعد كل هذول الناس
وحتى ما شايفه انه انا قويه ما شايفه هذا
الشيء فهل في قوه اكثر من كذا هذا قوه
احمد المصنف معاق المعاق غير ضعيف المعاق
الشخص من حقه ان يعيش كل انسان فينا عنده
اعاقته الخاصه المسميات لا تعني شيء
الوحيد اللي بخافوا منه هدول انه يخسروا
اهاليهم
ما عندهم اي شيء تقول لك انا اخاف انه
اصحى القى امي ما موجوده اصبح عندهم خوف
لانه احنا اصبحنا الامتداد لامان مش
المجتمع لازم يتغير المجتمع ككل في انه
يشعروا الاولاد بالامان ومن ثم بيجي
التنافس بيجي
الرغبه في انه الواحد يحقق ذاته الاولاد
غير شاعرين بالامان امانهم احنا
فاحنا لازم نعطي اولادنا الامان عشان نطلب
من المجتمع يعطينا الامان
تخرجوا مننا مجموعه من الشباب وشغالين
الان في جهات حكوميه في ايمي كل شغالين
الان عندنا في سيمنس للانرجي وبرواتب ما
شاء الله تظاهر رواتب بتاعه الخريجين من
الجامعات فلابد ان يكون لها دور الاولاد
خبره مهاره حتى يستطيعوا ان ينافسوا في
سوق العمل حسب امكانياته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وانا 18 سنه
[موسيقى]
انا انا كاين انا بحب سعيد عالم
بحب اكون مع عائلتي
انا بشوف انه في حب بجوات كل العالم ابي
عندهم منيح جواته حتى يلي منه منيح
كيف توصي لنا محمود
[موسيقى]
شغل سنين من حياتك تتذكري لما قلت لك انا
انه انا كنت عم فتش على فاتن فانا كنت عم
بدرس يعني بنفس الوقت عم بدرس اللي انا
بحبه وبنفس الوقت عم برضي ضميري كام اني
انا عم بدرس شيء بقدر اساعد فيه ابني
نقدر نحن نسيطر على السلوك اما بالتعزيز
او بالعقاب فنحن بس نعرف شو هو المعزز
الافضل للطفل نحن بنقدر نستخدمه
لنقدر نعلم الطفل الطلب انه يقدر يطلب
ويعبر عن حاله مش ضروري يكون الطلب بالحكي
لانه في كثير اطفال ما بيحكوا فنحن الطلب
ممكن نحن نستعمل صور ممكن نستعمل
لحتى نقدر نتواصل معه وهو يتواصل معنا فهو
نحن نعد الطلب هو من اهم القصص اللي احنا
بنعلمه للطفل منبلش فيها اقص اساسيه لنبلش
فيها مع الطفل لانه هي نحن هي مفتاح
التواصل اذا بدك
بصراحه بالمراحل الاولى اللي هي كانت اصعب
مرحله علي انا كنت عيد السشنز كل يوم اللي
بياخذها مع الاخصائي كنت عيد السيشن اربع
مرات بالنهار جلسات النطق كنت ارجع اعيدهم
بحذافيرهم بنفس النهار
بالوقت اللي ما كنت عم بعطي انا جلسات
النطق ارجع اعيدها كن انا عم بعمل معه
نشاطات بقلب البيت فلما صار هو ردي لما
صار هو جاهز لحتى نعرضه لتجارب نكتشف هو
شو بحب بلشنا بقى نجرب جربنا كمبيوتر
وجربنا
البروجرام وجربنا يعني ما في شيء ما جربني
لاكتشفنا انه محمود بارع بالبيانو بيقدر
يعبر عن حاله بالبيانو عن غضب وعن فرحه
دقله لبابا اذا بدك
يوم اجت تسويقي يصورني بالبيت
عند خالو حمودي
ماذا لو طلب منا ان نتوقف لحظه ونلبس رداء
هذه الام او الاخت او ذلك الاب او الاخ
للحظه فقط ماذا لو ادركنا ان احد اطفالنا
مصاب بطيف توحد
جميع من تحدثنا اليهم لم يتمنوا تغيير
الادوار وانما طالبوا ممن هم حولهم او من
يصادفونهم في الشارع او في المتجر او
السينما او المدرسه في اي مكان تمنو ان
يمنح هؤلاء الماره اطفال التوحد القليل من
التفاهم وشيئا من الحب
يؤلمني ان اراه يكبر وهو مازال بهذه
البراءه والطفوليه ربما لانني اخاف عليه
من براءته ونظافه تفكيره وحبه المطلق
للبشر وعدم ادراك الشر الموجود في هذه
الدنيا
التاسيس كتير صعب مرحله كتير صعبه التاسيس
اللي هو انك تعلمي اول كلمه ينطقها اول
حرف يكتبه جدا مرحله صعبه من اصعب المراحل
وبنفس الوقت تحدي البلوغ
الهرمونات لما تلعب دور والسلوك قديش
بيتاثر كمان هيدا تحدي جديد وللاباء
شكرا لكم فانكم وقفتوا بجانبنا وساعدتونا
في ابنائنا وبقول للتخلوا عن ابنائهم
ارجعوا لابنائكم محتاج لكم ما تخجلوا من
ابنائكم امتداد لكم قد لا يكون ابنك كما
حلمت فيه ولكن شيء اخر لم تحلم به اقبل
ابن احسن لي انه احمد يكون موجود كده ولا
يكون احمد ما موجود في الحياه اتمنى احمد
يكون موجود مدى الحياه حتى لو كان بهذا
الشكل انا الان لكن مش يكون احمد ما موجود
في حياتي
[موسيقى]
شو بتحب تقول لبابا دقيت بيانو
اذا بتحب تحكي على التلفون مثلا اذا هو مش
هون
[موسيقى]
ورسم ورياضه
والتردمه والسباحه شو بتفوت بتعمل بالمطبخ
بعمل
[موسيقى]
طبعا نقدر على الدنيا بحالها
كلي تبان صعبه طول اله
مع بعض انا وانت اكيد هنكمل
[موسيقى]
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا